WE WANT TO TURN TO THE VIDEOTAPE
THAT'S COMING FROM THE PRESS
POOL.
THEY ARE JUST GETTING OUT AND
QUEUING UP THE TAPE.
STAND BY AS WE GET READY TO GO
IN THE CABINET ROOM WHERE THE
PRESIDENT'S MEETING.
>> JUST HEARD THEY BROKE INTO
THE OFFICE OF ONE OF MY PERSONAL
ATTORNEYS, A GOOD MAN.
IT'S A DISGRACEFUL SITUATION.
IT'S A TOTAL WITCH HUNT.
I'VE WANTED TO KEEP IT DOWN.
WE'VE GIVEN I BELIEVE OVER A
MILLION PAGES WORTH OF DOCUMENTS
TO THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THEY CONTINUE TO JUST GO
FORWARD.
HERE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT SYRIA.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF
SERIOUS THINGS WITH THE GREATEST
FIGHTING FORCE EVER.
I HAVE THIS WITCH HUNT
CONSTANTLY GOING ON FOR OVER 12
MONTHS NOW.
ACTUALLY MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
YOU COULD SAY WAS RIGHT AFTER I
WON THE NOMINATION IT STARTED.
IT'S A DISGRACE.
IT'S FRANKLY A REAL DISGRACE.
IT'S AN ATTACK ON OUR COUNTRY IN
A TRUE SENSE.
IT'S AN ATTACK ON WHAT WE ALL
STAND FOR.
SO WHEN I SAW THIS AND WHEN I
HEARD IT, I HEARD IT LIKE YOU
DID.
I SAID THAT IS REALLY NOW A
WHOLE NEW LEVEL OF UNFAIRNESS.
SO THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON.
I SAW ONE OF THE REPORTERS WHO
WAS NOT NECESSARILY A FAN OF
MINE, NOT NECESSARILY VERY GOOD
TO ME.
HE SAID IN EFFECT THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS NOW GETTING RIDICULOUS.
THEY HAVE FOUND NO COLLUSION
WHATSOEVER WITH RUSSIA.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION AT ALL.
NO COLLUSION.
THIS IS THE MOST BIASED GROUP OF
PEOPLE.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE THE BIGGEST
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST I'VE EVER
SEEN.
DEMOCRATS ALL OR JUST ABOUT ALL.